you know we've heard quite a lot over
the last four years about uh
quote unquote misinformation and now as
trump
challenges the ostensible results of the
election
this campaign by the media to combat
what they call misinformation has gone
into overdrive everywhere they look now
they're finding this misinformation some
of the headlines just over the last few
hours
uh quote the misinformation media
machine amplifying trump's election lies
election misinformation continues
staying up on youtube misinformation
channels claim biden is no longer
president-elect
that's not true internet sleuths use
misinformation in an attempt to prove
dead people voted in michigan and on or
not now you'll notice of course that the
word misinformation
is only ever used to apply to
conservatives and conservative outlets
and i don't think i'm exaggerating her
i'm not aware of a single case ever of
the mainstream media
labeling a leftist claim as
misinformation
and that's not because leftists never
engage in it we'll have more on that in
just a minute
kevin roose of the the new york times is
on the misinformation beat
he tweeted this out uh yesterday he said
facebook is absolutely teeming with
right-wing misinformation right now
these are all among the 10 most engaged
urls on the platform over the last 24
hours
then he provides screenshots of four
misinformation articles
one of them written full disclosure by
the daily wire the headlines are these
are the headlines these are the
misinformation headlines okay listen to
these
republican in michigan goes from loser
to winner after technical glitch fixed
officials urge confidence in system
michigan legislature
holds rare emergency session to
investigate irregularities
attorney general william barr authorizes
doj to look into voting irregularities
and purdue loftler call on georgia
secretary of state to resign
over election those are the
misinformation headlines
the problem with calling them
misinformation of course is that
they all happen to be true the
misinformation here is in labeling them
misinformation
now after a bunch of people pointed this
out ruse followed it up with this he
said
for the conservatives who are mad about
this yes it is possible for a story to
be factually accurate
and for it to be part of a
misinformation campaign
aimed at undermining confidence in the
election okay so do you understand that
a story can be factually accurate and
also be
misinformation factually accurate
misinformation that's what we're dealing
with now then he starts scrambling to
make his position seem coherent
because of course it's totally
incoherent finally he settles on this he
says
we need a better word than
misinformation to distinguish between
totally false stories and true stories
that are published in service of an
attempt to mislead people
but nobody who studies this stuff is
confused by what's happening
okay true stories that are published in
the service of an attempt to mislead
people
do you mean like i don't know this
segment that aired on abc news
suggesting that the defense secretary
getting fired might mean that trump is
on the verge of
staging a military coup listen to this
well martha you've covered washington
you've covered the pentagon for years
have you ever seen an interim period
like this a defense secretary out
three more top pentagon officials
tonight and if this is unsettling for
folks at home what do your sources tell
you tonight is there any concern that
this could put national security at risk
you know david no one has seen anything
like this there
is concern about what this means is the
president planning a military operation
or the use of federal troops which esper
opposed
even mitch mcconnell praised esper today
and republican john cornyn a member of
the senate gop leadership said of
trump's decision to fire
esper i don't think it helps him
and i don't think it helps the country
now the insinuation that trump is about
to declare himself
military dictator of the country seems
an awful lot to me
like misinformation and so does it so
does this from bloomberg
published yesterday it says for perhaps
the first time in american history
a coordinated effort to taint or
overturn a presidential election
may be underway yes bloomberg has pulled
out the flashy thing from men in black
and they're attempting now to wipe out
our memory of the last four years
so has cnn uh here's a segment they
aired just this morning
when it comes to claims about mass voter
fraud let's be clear
trump supporters you're being lied to
donald trump has a history of lying
loudly turning
baseless accusations into play to the
base articles of faith
now the goal is often to create a fake
scandal to distract from a real one
but when the accusation is actually
investigated
by republicans in congress or the trump
justice department
it comes up empty because there was
never anything there
okay fake scandals that fall apart
upon further investigation i can
think of quite a few of those personally
such as for example
pretty much every single trump scandal
over the last four years
but the media will never call their own
misinformation
misinformation that's never going to
happen so what do they really mean
when they use the term well i think that
kevin roose made it clear being for a
moment
uh more honest than he meant to be
to the media and also to the big tech
companies like facebook and twitter
a fact can still be misinformation
even if it's a fact it can still be
misinformation if it's inconvenient
or offensive to some favored group of
people anyway
or if it might lead people to a
conclusion
at which our overlords and truth
ministers do not want
us to arrive and often the forbidden
conclusion
is the right conclusion but even if it
isn't i mean even if some set of true
facts
may really be interpreted by some group
of people in the wrong way
set them down the wrong path that's no
excuse to censor the facts
or to mislabel them as false when they
aren't
people don't need to be protected in
this way an important part of being an
adult and an american in a free country
in the information age
is to pursue facts and form conclusions
using your own discernment
we don't need daddy cnn or mommy
facebook to hold our hands and
guide us this way or that besides if you
want to talk about
cherry-picked facts half-truths out of
context
tidbits being used in service of an
attempt to mislead as
the new york times says i could think of
no better example of that in modern
times
than what we've witnessed over the past
five or six months in cities across the
country police shootings
caught on tape posted online without
context or with dishonestly framed
context
and spread by the media in order to
convince people that racist cops are
prowling the streets
murdering innocent minorities at will
now
there is an example of how a reality the
reality that
that so and so was shot by the cops can
be presented in such a way as to cause
people to form conclusions
that are wildly off-base and dangerous
and destructive but even then
i wouldn't be in favor of censorship to
solve the problem
instead people who know the truth have
to stand up
speak it and battle the lies head on
that's the only way to deal with it
the left relies on on forms of
censorship and by the way
a major media outlet baselessly labeling
a truthful thing as misinformation
is a form of censorship let's be clear
about that especially because they know
that big tech's going to take that and
run with it
but they rely on these strategies
because they don't have the truth on
their side
they cannot meet you out on the
battlefield of ideas
and present their side that way they can
only shout you down
shut you down shut you up label you
maybe throw a molotov cocktail through
your window
for good measure these are the weapons
of liars and con artists
con artists these are their tactics
and we should be sure not to fall for it
hey you
uh yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated